an interesting study came out with pot
pot is hot these days the Boston Medical
Center and the Boston University School
of Medicine have found according to this
new study that marijuana has no negative
effects on human health that's right
let's take a look at some of the study
they found that no differences between
daily marijuana users and those using no
marijuana in their use of the emergency
room hospitalizations medical diagnoses
or their health status our findings
suggest that the marijuana use has
little measurable effect on
self-reported health or healthcare
utilization and adults using drugs
identified in a primary care clinic so
this is obviously linking health
directly to marijuana use and they're
not seeing any discrepancies I'm going
to guess that this doesn't surprise any
of the three of us Rick I start with you
once again I think they read their mail
just like dr. Sanjay Gupta suddenly read
his mail and said dude you want to stay
on the air you got a lot of people are
furious with you you gotta give that up
so pretend it's a giant epiphany and
change in your position on air you're
got five right something good and go
yeah and I think a lot of probably knew
but we knew a long time ago but as
pharmaceutical backers which might mean
they are coming closer to their own
cannabinoid pharma version of everything
that'll work this time the one says okay
it tell Sanjay he can ease up a little
bit yeah well that's interesting because
in the quote it kind of tells you that
right yeah but that's a really
interesting theory I think that you
think that there's somehow going to
figure out the the farm pharmacological
version and then one of the bloom
industries that's saving California and
saving Washington and saving Colorado
they're the economies are boosting up
like crazy from it like someone who had
the previous power base is going to pay
a ton of attention to that and have huge
long death oak desk meetings about what
they're going to do to have their piece
of that yeah like the way cigarette
companies are figuring out now what
packaging will look like yeah and this
isn't just the business model it is that
means an inevitability when they have
the new munching meal from Burger King
right Mudge if everyone's prepping and
ramping for it so you'll get you'll get
the weed next door to Burger King and
then you'll go in for the punch you know
at Burger King
um so obviously this this doesn't
surprise us but do you I mean what what
is it about everybody that takes them so
on so Sanjay Gupta is a good example
because and I and I know your answer
already but he was one of these people
that was completely against it then he
had this huge Maher culpa couple weeks
ago everything I knew was wrong but I'm
not a doctor I knew that it was okay so
all have for a very long time I think
there's two factors going in here I
think you're absolutely right I think
that even in that statement that you
just read you could see that the
language they're using is starting to
move towards it has no impact on people
seeking treatment it has no impact on
the weight of the healthcare systems
what they're essentially saying they're
saying emergency rooms and people coming
in for treatment or no sicker are
needing no more care no more financing
from the government or anybody and I
think they're also paving the way for it
to be legal so they could get money from
it and all they need to do is flip the
switch in certain people who need the
authorities to tell you so right now we
have lots of older baby boomers we have
lots of conservative with other people
that like authoritarian like it or not
some people like authoritarian things to
be told to them before making their
decisions some people are just more
comfortable that way they're not
comfortable getting their information
from the internet or common sense they
like to be told ABC equals this you know
so I think that once the government and
once more studies funded by universities
and watch people like authorities like
dr. Sanjay Gupta who's now an authority
apparently CNN great but that's gonna
mean it's people more comfortable now
with it so we all knew this I think
people that are forward-thinking know
this but it's just that last you know
there's like the early adopters and
there's that last way but they need to
be told it's okay and I always go we
have the early adopters that sounds
great what are what are the people who
have to drag at the end we the dumb deaf
and blind I don't know the dumb dumb
well thanks to the blind people and deaf
people that are at home going I knew
that and you know come on right so just
playing the devil's advocate here as I
have to do occasionally is there any
risk in this that if you if you make all
this stuff if you make we illegal that
then kids will be trying it younger and
when their brains are forming and you
know the cognitive parts of their brain
and they're putting in weed that often
now is much stronger than it used to be
and all that kinda stuff is
refer to the alcohol model between the
20s and now is that is maybe there's a
prohibition to a canceling prohibition
model you can look at for that and they
could check the stats on that it's an
interesting good question I don't know
what the numbers would be for that yeah
but I see you're kidding you want to
drink when you're in junior high or high
school you're probably gonna have a few
drinks the same way if you were gonna
smoke pot you were gonna smoke pot I
think you are correct by saying it's
like prohibition I don't think saying
that it's legal for medical purposes is
going to entice a kid like Oh for
medical purposes this is cool it's
cooler for me to smoke now I think it
may be you'll be make it a little less
cool that's a kind of a medicinal thing
rather than you know like a naughty
thing or just to get messed up right and
the second you can get it at the
Starbucks of weed it won't be cool
anymore so final thought on this 2016 is
there a chance that one of the
candidates that a real sort of
mainstream candidate is going to get on
board at least legalizing it at the
state level I can see maybe somebody
doing that is that is that totally crazy
right candidate possibly who will defer
to that but will not come out in support
of it okay so somebody probably a
Republican who's big on states rights I
will get no traction really or a
Democrat could say it too but they would
just say it's not federal government's
responsibility look what Democrats would
be it would behoove them to do that so
they could say look we're not trying to
be big government regulate you let the
state's decide and kind of say look
Republicans if that's what you like then
you just like my policy it'll be the
candidate on the ropes right pull out
the pup boy boom throw that out the hay
but I may have all these scandals but
look what I brought here I got weed for
everybody
let's head oh you'll vote for me we like
that guy we don't know who he is what we
like
hey guys the Reuben report is brought to
you by Cooper comm they've got 75% off
dog and cat choose toys accessories home
goods and more use code RR for 20% off
your next purchase the link is right
down there